اهلا من جديد كشفت وول ستريت جورنال ان
مجموعه تاميتا الشركه الام للفيسبوك
وانستجرام تعتزم تسريحه الاف الموظفين
اعتبارا من اليوم الاربعاء نقلت الصحيفه
عن مصادر ان رئيسه تنفيذيه للمجموعه مارك
زوكربيرج يريد انهاء خدماتي حوالي يتناشر
الف موظف بالشركه
وكشف تقييم هؤلاء الموظفين انهم من اصحاب
الاداء الضعيف تعاني المنصات الالكترونيه
التي يرتكز نموذجها الاقتصادي على
الاعلانات من خفض المعلنين للانفاق بسبب
تضخم العالمي وارتفاع معدلات الفائده
ويعملوا في مجموعه متى حوالي 87 الف موظف
في جميع انحاء العالم بحسب ارقام نهايه
سبتمبر ايلولا الماضي وتراجعت الارواح
الصافيه للمجموعه باكثر من 50 في المئه
على اساس سنويا لتبلغ حوالي 4 مليارات و
400 مليون دولار تقريبا في الفصل الثالث
من العام الجاري وفقره اسهم متى حوالي 70%
من قيمتها هذا العام وقالت ان متوسط سعر
اعلانها انخفض بحوالي
18% تقريبا على اساس سنويا